[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORDANNA CHORD:
Welcome, everyone.
My name is Jordanna,
and this is Scott,
and we're here to talk to you
about the latest innovations
in Cloud data loss prevention.
First, an order of business.
We'll be using the Dory app
within the Cloud Next app
to take questions, and then
at the end of the talk,
we'll be going through those.
Josh is our moderator, and he'll
be helping you through those.
Anything we don't
get to today, we'll
be covering-- or responding to
you before the end of the week.
So in this session, we'll
be giving a quick overview
of Cloud data loss
prevention, followed
by a review of the
latest things we've
launched since the
last time we were here.
Scott will then demo
all of the new features,
and then we'll end
with your questions.
So why are we here today?
For those of you
new to Cloud DLP,
it provides a collection of
tools that classify and detect
for sensitive information,
anonymize and transform
text and images, and measure
your protection with risk
analysis.
Why did we build Cloud
data loss prevention?
We made DLP to help you
understand and manage
your sensitive data.
We made DLP for your data
compliance officers, your data
engineers, your
academic researchers who
all need help to
assure compliance
with policies and regulations.
And most importantly,
they need help
to protect your users' data.
So how do we do that?
DLP is made up of three
pillars, the first of which
is discovery and classification.
A compliance
officer whose job is
to ensure that credit
card data is protected
can use DLP to
tokenize the data.
But to be really sure
they've done a thorough job,
they need to conduct audits
of all the persistent data
in your company to make
sure that credit cards don't
show up anywhere surprising.
DLP can help this compliance
officer find and identify
credit card data along with
many other types of PII
across BigQuery, Google
Cloud Storage, and Datastore,
and even data not
stored in the Cloud.
The findings can
then be used to take
remediation steps, such as
anonymization, which takes us
to our next pillar.
DLP provides support to
de-identify text and images
in both structured and
unstructured contexts.
We host a number of
transformation techniques
such as masking, deletion, and
format preserving encryption
to obscure your data while
minimizing your data loss.
Here's an example of a user
combining the first two product
pillars.
As you can see, we
have a loan application
with several bits of PII.
On the right hand
side is what the image
and what the documents
look like after they've
been run through DLP.
As you can see, our
detectors have automatically
identified the phone, the email,
and the social security number
at the top.
We've color coded the
findings so that viewers
might know what was redacted,
but not what exactly
private information was there.
Treating rich documents as
images and anonymizing them
this way is a great technique
to protect your user's data.
But we aren't quite
done yet, which
brings us to our next pillar.
A medical researcher
is conducting a study,
and their ethics board has asked
that they remove all ability
to tie the secret lab
result back to the patients
before publishing
their research.
They've removed all of the
identifying information--
the social security numbers
and the ages and the dates
of birth--
and they've left no
direct identifiers behind.
But to be sure that their
patients' identity is
protected, they turn
to risk analysis.
In this extremely
simple example,
we can see that
there's outliers,
and that in this case, the
job title field is really
identifying, even
though normally this
wouldn't be considered PII.
Risk analysis help
users find data
like this
automatically-- data that
is actually very revealing if
joined with another data set.
We provide a number
of metrics which
can increase your
understanding of the risks
that your data might
pose if it were to leak,
or if you were to
share it intentionally
for research purposes.
So those are the three pillars
that make up Cloud DLP.
So let me tell you a
little bit about what we've
launched new in the last year.
DLP has a support
for detectors which
are effective at finding common
types of private information,
and we support custom
detectors which
enable you to search for
unique business data.
But this new feature,
detection rules,
allows you to refine the
results found by those detectors
by modifying their behavior
to reduce noise and increase
precision.
Let me show you
two quick examples.
In this case, we have a data
set that we're going to be
de-identifying that has both
company email addresses--
those owned by my employees--
and customer email addresses.
I don't want to redact my
employee email addresses.
In fact, I'd like to
leave those alone,
and I don't want them to
show up in findings reports.
By setting up an exclusion
rule, in this case
I'd just tell it to exclude
support@example.com findings.
You can support dictionaries
here or regular expressions so
that you can exclude these
from your findings and only
redact your customer
email addresses.
Here's a second example.
In this data example, we have
a data set that has names
that we'd like to redact.
The doctor names aren't
important to protect,
but the patient names
we need to redact.
Because they both
show up as findings
in the normal
operating mode, they'd
both be redacted as equals.
But in this case, I can
boost the likelihood
of my patient names by including
a hot word rule that looks
for words nearby the name--
in this case, the word patient--
and I boost the certainty.
And by setting min
likelihood to very likely,
the only names that will get
redacted are my patient names,
and the doctor names
will be left alone.
So for a while now we've
supported custom dictionaries,
which were ideal when
you had a short list
of secretive or sensitive words
that you wanted to scan for,
but they didn't work if you had
a list of words that changed
frequently, or if your
list was long, which brings
us to stored dictionaries.
Stored dictionaries
are easy to update
and they support tens
of millions of entries.
They're great for things
like, as in the picture,
user ID dictionaries.
There's no pattern
or regular expression
I can use to detect for these,
but if you give me a store
dictionary, I can find these
in both your structured and
unstructured data.
So now that I've
given you the ability
to fine tune your findings,
the next set of features
are about modifying
what you scan.
If you're scanning
BigQuery or Cloud storage,
scanning all of the content
may not be necessary.
Sometimes a million findings
is no more meaningful
than one finding, and it's
certainly not always the most
cost effective strategy.
So with this, we've
offered several new ways
to sample your data.
I'll quickly show two
very simple examples.
In this example, we're
scanning a BigQuery table.
And I'm going to limit the scan
to select 1,000 rows randomly
from the table.
Each row is about
equally the same to me,
and so this allows me
to get a sense of what
type of private information
is in the table.
I can do the same thing
with Google Cloud Storage.
It works a little differently.
In this case, I
give it a bucket,
and I say select 25% randomly
of the files in this bucket
but only scan 200
bytes of those.
By doing this quick
check, I can completely--
I can check for
potential problems
without incurring the
costs of exhaustive scans.
If I joined this with
scheduled triggers,
I can spot check my buckets
on a regular cadence
to assure there are no
regressions as new data is
being added to my buckets.
Finally, our
biggest announcement
we have today to
share with you is
our launch of the beta of
our Cloud DLP in the console.
Here you'll be able to
schedule inspection jobs,
manage templates, and evaluate
findings, which takes us
to our time to demo,
where Scott will show you
this UI along with all of
our other new features.
SCOTT ELLIS: Great.
Thank you, Jordanna.
So I'm going to walk
through a lot of the stuff
that Jordanna just
talked about and show you
some examples of using our
Cloud DLP infrastructure
kind of in action.
Just to get started,
we'll start with our UI.
I'm just going to walk
through creating an inspection
job, which is a very
powerful, but a simple thing
to do in the UI.
So what we see when we get
here is we see a list of jobs
that we've run.
These are situations we've
gone in and inspected something
like BigQuery or Cloud storage.
We've also got a section
called job triggers.
Those, again, are jobs that
you might trigger or repeat
on a regular basis.
So I've got a couple of examples
here of jobs that are going
to run in a regular cadence.
Maybe you want to run these
daily, weekly, monthly, things
like that.
And you can go in and edit
your templates as well.
What I'm going to start off--
we'll just create a job.
And let's see--
let's call this--
and we're going to go
look at Cloud storage.
And I'm just going
to run this job.
I'm going to go find a
bucket that we have here,
which kind of represents a--
like, a shared bucket
across our company
has a lot of different
data in there.
I simply pick the bucket.
I'm going to jump into some
of the advanced configuration
to show you some
of those features
that Jordanna talked about.
First, you can include
an exclude path.
Maybe there's certain file
types you don't want to scan,
or certain ones you
only want to scan,
but let's go ahead and
jump into sampling here.
So I'm going to pick
to do a random sample
of the first megabyte of
every file in that bucket,
and then we'll just select to
scan about 50% of our files
in that bucket.
So with that simple
configuration,
Cloud DLP will take
care of the rest.
It will basically go
in, scan that bucket,
randomly sample the files.
When it finds a file
that's in the sample,
it's going to only scan a
random sample of the first--
of up to one megabyte.
So this gives us a good sample.
And now, we might have
really large files in there,
so this helps us kind
of get that spot check.
Now, for detection,
I'm just going
to have it scan for a couple
of different things here.
Let's say we look for credit
card numbers, email addresses.
Let's see here.
We'll do social
security numbers.
And again, these are
the built in types,
so just very simply I can select
them, add them in, and go.
So the next section
here is actions.
Now, actions are
basically, what happens
when this job completes?
What do I want to do with it?
We can publish a
Pub/Sub notification,
so you can pick that up and
kind of programmatically
assess the results.
You can save detail
findings to BigQuery.
This is a very
common option to do,
and it's very popular
because you actually
get the detailed
results of the findings.
You can publish to Cloud
Security Command Center.
If you're familiar
with that, it basically
is a way to aggregate a lot
of signals into one place,
or just notify by email
job status, job done,
things like that.
We can set up a schedule
to run this periodically,
but for this one, I'm
just going to run it.
We get the configuration there
in case you want to use that.
And then we just create the job.
So again, it's that easy.
This job is going to run.
It's going to look
for the three things
that I specified in that
config, and then we'll
be notified when it's done.
But what I'm going to do is I'm
going to jump over to a trigger
that we created earlier.
And so, again, we just scanned
kind of the company share.
But I wanted to kind of walk
through another common scenario
that we see, which is--
let's imagine that your
company has a website.
And you've got assets that power
that website that are public.
And you want to host those
in a Cloud storage market.
So I'm going to go ahead and
open up this bucket here,
and it's just called
company website.
And you'll see in that
little indicator at the top
that it's a public bucket,
and we're hosting things
like our images, HTML, CSS,
maybe some videos, things
that we want to share publicly.
But one concern I have
is I want to make sure
that no employees go in
and throw sensitive data
in that bucket because
then it would be exposed.
So to do that, I've created a
trigger that is going to run,
and I'll just kind of
walk through what that is.
So it's going to basically
scan that bucket.
We're basically looking at
the company website bucket.
We're going to scan
it recursively.
And we're going to publish
the findings into BigQuery
so we can look at the details.
What was found?
Where was it found?
And I'm also including an
option called include quote.
And what that does
is it will actually
include the quote of the value
because I want to go in and see
what was found.
And I'm going to lock
down that BigQuery table.
This is a table
under my control.
So I'm going to put that in
there and lock that down.
And you could run
this every day,
but for this we're just
basically going to run this,
and you can do a run now.
So clicking Run Now
here will kick off a job
and just run it right now.
The other thing that
I'm doing as well
is I'm only scanning
the difference.
So let me show you what
that looks like here.
When you do set
up a periodic run,
you can basically have
it only scan new content.
So in this case, because
it's my public website,
I'm doing an exhaustive
scan, but let's say
next week when I run it again,
or tomorrow when I run it
again, I only want to look
at things that have changed
or things that are new.
So the first time I ran this--
let me pull up that job here.
The first time I ran this,
I ran on the public website
and found two things.
I found email address
and phone number.
Now, this wasn't too
shocking because it
was a public website.
We expect to find
something on there.
So let me go ahead and look
at what that looks like.
So I'm going to jump into the
detailed findings in BigQuery.
And what this does is
it takes us directly
into the findings for that job.
And I have a query
here I'm going to run.
And as you see in
this query, we're
basically just
selecting a few fields.
And we're going to limit
it to that one job run
because I want to show what
that baseline scan looked like.
And let's see here-- just
scroll this up a little bit.
And as you'll see here,
we found two things.
We found a company phone number,
and we found a company email
address.
Not a big deal.
Right?
That's totally fine.
We're happy with that.
They're on that particular
web page, so that's great.
That's our baseline scan.
So what I wanted to make
sure of is that something
didn't change over time.
Let's jump back, and let's
go back to that trigger.
So when I ran this
trigger again,
the next time nothing was there.
So we just got, again, no
results, nothing scanned,
no new files.
But then when I ran
it the third time,
it looks like
something was in there.
A bunch of data
has now showed up.
We saw a huge spike.
We saw 10,000 email addresses,
10,000 social security numbers,
and we also saw this thing--
a hit for a custom type
called a custom designed doc.
So again, that's very alarming.
Clearly, this doesn't sound
like something that should
be on our public website.
And if we dive in and look
at the findings here--
let's just build
a query live here.
And I'm just going
to look at star.
And as we see here, we're
actually seeing the raw data.
Now, this is all fake
data that we made up,
but in your real scenario,
this is the actual data.
You can see what it is.
You can see where it was.
It looks like somebody
uploaded in this temp folder
an export CSV file that clearly
had some sensitive data in it.
We also had that one
design doc, so we
want to try to find
out where that is.
Now, what I'm doing
here is I'm looking
at the raw SQL in
BigQuery, and you
can run any kind
of analytics you
would run in SQL directly here.
What that also means is
that you can use Data
Studio to visualize this data.
So I'm going to open
up an audit report
that we built that was built
on top of that SQL query--
that SQL database--
and I've just
done some very, very
simple visualization here.
We see we've got some
jobs that have run.
And I wanted to look
at this kind of results
here and narrow down where
we saw that design doc.
So I'm just going do a
very simple filter here.
And if we see, there's
a file in that bucket
that looks like it had
a hit for a design doc.
So let's go see what
that looks like.
So I'm in my public bucket here.
Go to that temp folder.
We see that export folder
that had that CSV with all
the personal data.
We see a screenshot folder
with a bunch of screenshots.
And if I open up
this one screenshot,
what we're seeing
here is it looks
like somebody took a
screenshot of our design doc
and uploaded it to the website.
And we have a custom type that's
looking for our design doc
identifiers.
So we OCR this doc
as part of that scan,
found our design doc
identifier in that doc,
and flagged it as a hit.
Again, that was a custom design
doc detector that we built.
So very simply, whether
it's through BigQuery,
running SQL, or a
simple audit report,
I'm able to get in and
find that information
and identify, again, that change
between that baseline scan
and the next scan.
Now, I'm going to go
back to one slide here.
Now, clearly, if you
have a public bucket,
finding that data--
monitoring for that
data-- is very crucial.
But you also might
want to prevent it
from happening in
the first place.
Me finding out about it the
day after or the week after,
again, it's already there.
So you can also use
DLP to do things
like scan that data before it
gets moved into the bucket.
This is a reference
architecture.
There's a link at the bottom--
I know it's a little bit
long, but you can find
this on our website as well--
that basically takes
you through using
DLP and what we call kind of
a staged bucket approach where
before you move data
into a public bucket,
you would scan it
with DLP and have
the results of that job using
Cloud Functions actually
move the file in to the
public bucket or reject it.
So that's another way you
can apply this technique
to prevent the data from
getting in in the first place.
So now we're going to
go to a different demo.
We're going to go to an
example of using DLP--
we're going to use
the UI as well--
but we're going to apply it
to do something different.
We're going to look
at BigQuery, and we're
going to try to use DLP to
basically classify a table.
So to get started, let's
go look at that table.
I'm going to close a
couple of tabs here.
And in this example,
we have a data engineer
who uploaded a CSV file.
It didn't have a
header row, or it just
had fields one through seven.
We don't know what's in there.
Now, with a single table,
you can look at the table
and you can figure
out what's in there.
But imagine if you had
thousands of these tables
and you wanted to set up a
process where you could scan
it, look for certain things--
sensitive data-- and
use those findings
to try to classify the table.
And that's what we're
going to do today.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to go back
to our DLP triggers page.
So I've created this
trigger and I'll
walk through what
that looks like here.
So we're basically using
this trigger to scan a table.
I'll show it from here.
We're basically going to be
scanning that table that I just
showed.
Now, it's a big
table, so we don't
need to scan the whole thing.
We set it up to basically
do a random 10% sample,
and we're going to use those
results and try to collect--
kind of aggregate then to guess
what the classification is
of that table.
And let's go back here.
And I wanted to load
the job that we ran.
So when we look at the job
results, as you see here,
we found a lot of
different things.
So this is just giving us
a summary of the data--
credit cards, emails, IP
addresses, VIN number, SSN,
phone number.
We also set up two custom types.
Now, these were types similar--
if you remember the example
that Jordanna gave for a
large custom dictionary.
What we did is we
set up our user IDs
and we built two
big dictionaries--
one for our US users and
one for our European users.
And in this scan,
it looks like we
found about 7,000 examples of
US users and 3,000 of EU users,
and that's kind of showing the
power of these dictionaries.
Those dictionaries themselves
had millions and millions
of user data in them.
In this case, we just did a
sample scan of 10,000 rows,
and so we found about a good
70/30 percentage of that.
OK.
So now what we're
going to do is we're
going to jump in and let's look
at the actual BigQuery table.
Let's say-- I'm going
to go back here,
and let's just go straight
from here from the findings.
There we go.
So again, in that trigger,
what we did is we set this up.
We wrote the detailed
findings in BigQuery,
and now we're going to go
in and look at BigQuery
and see if we can use
that to understand
what's in that table.
OK.
So I'm going to load a
query here and run it.
So what this query
is doing is it's
taking the detailed
findings and it's basically
collecting all the findings.
You're going to get one
row for every finding,
but it's just doing a simple
collect those per field ID
because you're going to get the
field name, the table column,
all that stuff in there.
And as we see here,
we've basically
done that to apply
that to each field,
and we see that there's
a good pattern here.
The first column was
our user ID column.
Had, again, that mix of 70/30
of US and European users.
We see a VIN number,
email address, IP address,
phone number--
not completely, so not
all of them in there
hit as a phone number--
SSN, and credit card number.
So again, we're kind of walking
through this process manually,
but they did here is if you
had thousands of tables,
you could go in and apply
this sort of programmatically
and say, I want to apply this
to every new table coming in,
validate the schema.
Or in the case of this one,
it really didn't have one.
Identify if there's any
sensitive data in there,
and then be able to
get results like this.
OK.
And so that's applying our
large custom dictionaries,
and also applying kind
of a unique use of it
to basically go in and
classify a BigQuery table.
The next thing
we're going to do is
we're going to show how to apply
some of our exclusion rules,
and we're going to start off by
showing how you would use those
during a large
inspection job like what
we've been using the UI for.
And then right after
we're going to show
how you can apply that
same template that we
create in a real time scenario.
So first, I want to go
back to that first bucket
that we scanned when we
kind of created our own job.
So in that bucket, this is
kind of our company share--
a lot of stuff's in there--
there's a development folder
that somebody put a lot of logs
in there.
Now, these are supposed
to be development
logs that the whole
company can look at
and only have test data in them.
But again, we're concerned
something might leak in.
We want to set up a process
to monitor for that data.
And so what we're
going to do is we're
going to go into our data
loss prevention section.
I have created a job
trigger for this.
And first, I think what
we're going to do, though,
is we are going to create--
we're going to basically
do a sample scan.
So let me show you
the scan that we ran.
And what we wanted to do
is, before we exhaustively
scanned all of that
data, we wanted
to just do a sample to kind
of see the things we found.
Again, we expect to find
a lot of data that we kind
of don't care about-- all
of our test accounts--
so we want to see
what that looks like.
So what I did was
I created a job.
We ran this job, only
looked for email addresses.
And as you see,
even in that sample,
we found 21,000 email addresses.
These are log files.
Not a big surprise that there's
a lot of emails in there,
but we want to get a sense
of what these look like.
So again, right from here we're
going to jump into BigQuery.
Let's run a query here.
And we will see
what they look like.
So as we see, a
lot of emails are
coming in across all
of our log files,
but they all have
this testdlp.com email
address in there, which
is our test accounts.
So we're good.
We're happy with that.
But again, if I run
this job every day
and it comes up with 21,000
findings, or 30,000 findings,
it's not going to be very
useful for me when most of those
are ones I don't care about.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to go back
and we're going to create
an exclusion template.
So I'm going to show you
what that looks like.
We're going to show
a code sample here.
What I'm doing here is I'm
using our API Explorer.
I'm going to pull
up and show you
kind of in detail
what that looks like
and how simple it is.
So in this example, we're
showing the JSON representation
of a template.
And we simply turned
on three types
that we cared about--
email address, credit card,
and social security number.
And at the bottom,
we created a rule--
an exclusion rule-- that simply
says, if you see testdlp.com
in the result of an email
address, partial match,
just ignore it.
That way the prefix,
the user name,
whatever it is, we don't care.
It'll match on the
suffix and we'll be good.
I'm going to leave that one up.
Go to my job triggers page.
So that's the
template that we want
to use now for our
ongoing periodic scan,
and that way the
findings that we get
will be meaningful to us.
So we set those
up in a template--
in a trigger.
We are going to use this
email exclude template
that we just created,
that we just showed you.
We're going to do a exhaustive
scan now because, again, we
want to make sure
that there isn't
that one email
address or two email
addresses leaking into our logs.
So we did the sample scan to
figure out what was going on,
get a sense of what was there.
Now we did the exhaustive
scan to search for everything.
And let's see what happened.
We're going to open up the job.
And it looks like we
found two email addresses.
So this is actually
useful, right?
We went from 21,000 in
a small sample scan,
and now we scanned
about 626 megabytes
of log files that
are up there, and we
found two email addresses.
So these are probably ones
we really care about and want
to go look at.
So I'm going to jump
into the findings here.
Let's see here.
And just open up
this saved query.
What I'm doing here
is I'm basically
looking at just the results here
for that last scan that we did.
And again, it's
sample data here,
but these are two that are
not part of our test set.
It's the same email
address showed up twice
in this one log--
prod test logs five.
So clearly that prod test logs
five maybe wasn't a dev log
and shouldn't have
been in there.
And again, we've been able
to very easily identify
that using exclusion lists,
weeding out all the stuff we
didn't care about.
Now, to do that again, we
used this exclusion rule.
We applied it when we
did this large scan
where we basically
went in, scanned
600 and something
megabytes of data,
applied it in a large operation.
But that template
is very useful.
Again, that holds
the configuration
of what you care about,
what you're looking for.
What we're going
to do next is we're
going to use that
template and we're
going to apply it
in another scenario.
We're going to show
how that same template
and same exclusion rule
can be used in real time.
To do that, I'm going to pull
open a sample application
that we built,
and I'm just going
to load-- this is a live
classification demo that we
built in App Engine.
What it's doing is it's taking
the data that's on the left box
and automatically applying
one of our DLP inspection
and transforms, and then putting
the output in the right box.
So what we see here
is a sample chat
where we've got one of our
agents talking to a customer,
and we simply said, look
for a bunch of stuff
and just redact it
when you find it.
So on the right side, you
see all the emails have
been replaced with
email address, SSNs
with the US social
security number,
and credit cards replaced.
But again, we want to
apply that template now
because we didn't really want
to hide our agent's name.
We want to know who that is.
And in this case,
the james@testdlp.com
was hidden because we just
treated it as an email address.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go in here.
I'm going to load this template.
This is the-- hold on a second.
Let's see.
Template name.
I'm going to take this
template name that we created.
And in our live kind
of real time demo,
we have the ability just
to paste in a template.
So we're showing-- we're not
going to go edit the code,
we're just simply going to
have the application use
a different template.
I'm going to paste it in here.
And so now if I go back to this
and update it, what you see
is the right side refreshed as
soon as I typed something in,
and now we are no
longer excluding
the james@testdlp.com.
So again, just showing that
that one same template that we
copied straight from the
inspect job, applied here,
you can use it in all of your
kind of pipelines and workflows
and have that consistency,
and not have to go in
and change code.
Just simply reference
a different resource.
And again, that's using
our exclusion rules.
There's a lot more power
that you can do as well,
creating your own custom
types, exclusion rules,
combining those together.
All of that, again, no matter
how simple or complex it is
can be saved as a
template and then reused
across your workflows.
[MUSIC PLAYING]